don't you get nervous that we could make
spectacular discovery on Mars that not
only has there been life there's
actually like pretty Advanced Micro you
know or a multicellular life totally
thriving in certain regions we just
hadn't visited the man on Mars and we
make this big discovery that
um a relatively large percentage of
people just simply wouldn't believe it
they think it's all yeah 100 fake
and that they're just doing this to
control us and that blah blah like we
could make the most important discovery
in human life like in all of human
existence that that we're not alone in
this universe
by you know cellularly at least and a
good percentage of people I'm thinking
20 30 40 in today's world 40 plus
percent of people wouldn't even believe
it existed interesting I I I'd be it's
just a very important thing to think
about especially as an educator like
yourself
I think the the current cynicism towards
institutions and science is temporary I
think it's they're basically the
internet woke up
the internet smells [__] and it
looked at uh I'm sorry I'm not being
ageless but saying older scientists and
and they looked at them and they kind of
said you're kind of full of [__] you got
a lot of ego uh you're you speak down to
everybody you're not very good at
communicating I think there's a lot of
Truth to what they're saying and I think
the young scientists that are coming up
will be much better at not being full of
[__] being authentic being real not
treating uh people like their children
that can't possibly understand like
taking it very seriously that there's a
lot of intelligent people out there that
are curious they're this full of desire
for knowledge like being transparent
about all the uncertainties
of the scientific process all the
tensions the conflicts all of that and
it's I I think
I think once we fix the community
science Communication System adapted to
the internet
um I think that won't be an issue I I
hope I hope I mean that's that's why
people like you are really important is
it's like uh communicate with
authenticity
um
but yeah that's definitely something to
think about I mean yes the early uh I
mean listen scientists too like the
phosphine discovered on on Venus is like
they're extremely skeptical always uh so
definitely there will there will be a
lot of skepticism uh it and it depends
what it looks like if it kind of looks
like this thing kind of looks like
bacteria back on Earth uh yes uh so it
means contamination is very difficult to
avoid in general but if the thing looks
like fundamentally different yeah then
you're like all right yeah that like
totally different DNA RNA like this is
not we would never observe this ever
yeah then uh then you're like all right
cool of course uh so that another
promising thing that difficult to be
definitive about but let's get better
and better direct Imaging systems
there's now uh like I don't know how
many but thousands of planets are being
discovered outside of our solar system
there's moons being discovered now the
earth-like planets being discovered so
like all of that if you could do direct
Imaging of those planets more and more
and more uh there could be some gigantic
listen if there is like a Kardashian
have like type 2 civilization we're
gonna see the damn thing it's going to
be producing a lot of uh it's going to
be radiating a lot of energy so the
possibility of detecting someone that
that's also a real possibility with
something like James Webb telescopes
like those kinds of efforts that starts
becoming a reality